[Music]
lana
have a seat on the couch
oh
you're sitting far away today you must
have a whole lot you don't want to talk
about
i can always tell how anxious people
ought to talk to me about how close they
sit to me on the couch
i'm a little mad that pumpkin didn't
tell me that dr ish was here because
like at this point i'm tired of talking
about mama it's never nothing different
with her so whatever i guess i'll just
sit here and get through this
conversation as fast as possible
i feel like a lot has happened since the
last time we checked in
a lot has happened but
um i'm kind of over it at this point i
think i'm at the age where i'm not like
sitting there like oh i just wish my
mommy would come home you know like
mama's gonna do what mama's gonna do
whether we tell her not to or not
whenever i hear somebody tell me they're
over it the thing i hear underneath that
is
i don't believe i can actually get it to
be how i want it because if you did you
wouldn't be over it right
yeah but like now i'm at the point where
i'm like i don't think it would ever be
like how i wanted to be with my mama so
i just let the cards play and let her do
her
i hear a lot of just
exasperation you know this word it just
it just means you're tired
you know that tired of you tired of
believing and tired of getting your
hopes up
because every time it's like you get
your hopes up you get your hopes up like
i'm gonna graduate soon but like should
i even invite you to my graduation
because like are you even gonna come wow
think about what you just said
i don't know if i'm gonna invite my mama
to my high school
graduation because i might not be
important enough for her to even show up
or she's going to want to bring her
little friend like she's not going to
want to just come by herself
she's not going to be there just because
she wants to be there just for you
yeah
there's definitely been times where i've
cried about mama but mama just keeps
doing the same thing over and over again
keeps telling us she's gonna do this and
doing that but she never does any of it
so now i'm not gonna sit here and cry
over her anymore
[Music]